so watch the zoom is officially now
bigger than the top seven Airlines
combined in America again zoom is worth
forty point seventy billion dollars the
top seven airline Southwest Delta United
I AG Lufthansa American Airlines Air
France are worth forty six point two 1
billion dollars one company that got
started April 21st of 2011 nine years
ago in nine years this company went from
zero to forty eight point seven eight
billion dollars and watch this number
here here's an interesting stat December
of 2019 ten million people a day used
zoom ten million people a day you zoom
four months later it's 200 million a day
that's March April was three hundred
million people a day use zoom that means
in December just six months ago they can
only reach the city of New York that's
it only New York City knows about this
one product fast forward six months
later all of America uses zoom if we
were to put things into perspective
that's insanity but we got to look at
some other data here how did this
company become who they are today did
the guy who started and know what he was
doing that he get lucky the founders
name is Eric lon
okay he's today worth seven point eight
billion dollars more if you can zoom in
here seven point eight he was 22% of
zoom here's the most interesting part to
read about him Eric want worked in Japan
for four years after graduation inspired
by Bill Gates who worked in Japan in
1994 he moved to Silicon Valley in 1997
joined the tech boom at the time once
spoke very little English applied nine
times to be granted a visa from the
United States upon arriving in this
country joined WebEx which is a company
that doesn't do well right now they I
don't know how many webinars I do with
them that absolutely crashed in March
and I said we're on the calls with their
executive who said we can't use you
anymore because so many times it crashed
now watch what happens he joins WebEx a
video conferencing started the company
acquired by Cisco Systems in 2007 which
I think for like 3.2 billion dollars at
the time when she became the vice
president engineering in 2011 won
pitched a new smartphone friendly video
conferencing system
sisqó management the idea was rejected
one left Cisco to start
zum-zum is a publicly traded company and
now want is a billionaire
thanks to WebEx what's the moral to
story here here's what the moral
distorts a couple couple things about
zoom then we're gonna look at Airlines
number one luck
you've heard it call it luck is where
preparation meets opportunity you always
hear this that warlock is where
preparation meets opportunity so often
opportunity comes up where people can
get lucky and have the biggest change in
their lives but they're not ready for it
you know Brady was ready for blood so
Young was ready when Montana got hurt
Erick Juan was ready when the pandemic
came in true they went from 10 million
users a day to 300 million users a day
now watch the airline industry let's
look at some data here here's the
airline industry according to TSA if you
want to come up so it's like they can
see the website according to TSA okay
on March 1st okay we had two point two
eight million people traveling every day
March of 2019
it was 2.3 million people traveling so
not a big difference it's a drop-off of
20,000 people right if we go higher
you notice we went from two point two
two one seven two one six two one four
eight five two 953 we cracked a million
less than a million on March 17 so now
people are traveling less people are
scared 199 we're gonna lower Laurel or
118 we're going lower lower 94 we're
gonna lower Lord 87,000 people traveling
a day the airline industry went from 2.2
2.3 million people traveling on a daily
basis all the way down to 87 watch this
the 87,000 people that traveled in a day
look what it was a year prior to that
2.20 eight million okay two point two
zero eight million people traveling and
then you come up and you notice we went
from that 84 87 number to now as of
yesterday 230,000 people travel which is
good but it's not yet back to the
million or 500,000 or 1.5 million or two
million
we are still 2.2 million travelers
behind
last year so now when he seen numbers
like this where went from ten to one
from two million to two hundred thousand
that's a drop-off of nine ninety percent
a massive drop-off watch what happens
with the stock prices of these companies
let's take a look at this
American Airlines the last six months it
was hovering around twenty seven dollars
you know just a couple months ago right
before March 20 around 29 or 30 dollars
it went all the way down to right now
you can buy a share of American Airlines
for what 9.99 for $9.94 today you can
buy it right market cap dropped all the
way down to 4.2 1 billion dollars let's
go to the next one stay here Southwest
was twenty nine point nine twenty
gnocchi's fifty six dollars a share just
a couple months ago if you want to buy a
share 55:58 tonight you can buy for
twenty nine fifteen so it's not that big
of a drop-off right watch this United
went from same thing around eighty eight
eighty seven eighty five seventy nine
down to twenty five dollars you can buy
a share right now for twenty six dollars
give or take of United and then take a
look at Delta Delta was around sixty
bucks if you look at where they were at
three months ago they are right now
hovering around twenty three dollars so
now you look at that data right here's
what you think about you say I say to
myself at least I say so let me get this
straight
they were having 2.2 million people
traveling per day
to now only two hundred thousand people
traveling per day but the stock prices
have only dropped 50 percent and Warren
Buffett who own shares on four of them
ten percent minimum he sold all four of
them
why is he thinking it's gonna go Lord
then it's because if we do basic math
you know how some companies let's just
say you run a business and you have a
restaurant they shut you down you can't
have people coming in you're taking a
big hit you can pivot how do you pivot
you deliver more you bring food to
people right maybe you do different kind
of services you can still pivot and have
some kind of money coming in how do
airlines pivot what do they do
do airlines say I got 50 planes sitting
right here why don't you come to rent
one of them for 40 grand and put a party
in there I can't how to Airlines
okay you know we got these people that
like to take pictures in posted on
Instagram why don't you come and take a
picture saying I'm running this airline
look at me I'm by myself for $6,000 no
one's doing that today no one cares
about that stuff
how do airlines pivot actually think
about that how do our lines pivot uber
just announces they're letting go of
another 4,000 people how are they gonna
pivot if there's not a lot of
transportation taking place
here's the worldís story the airline
industry right now is a bit overvalued
right now based on some of the data that
you're seeing now don't get me wrong the
markets gonna recover once we go back to
traveling I don't know if we're gonna go
back to 2.2 million people traveling
every day any time so now I don't even
think it's gonna happen that quickly in
the next 30 60 90 days I think may take
a little longer than that but we're
eventually gonna go there they still
have taken a hit government keeps
bailing them out it's fake money if the
government if the government doesn't
bail out these guys and give them money
you better believe this wouldn't be down
50% this would be down 90% that means
the real price without a bailout of
Delta instead of $60 it should be $6
today not $23 that means and American
Airlines that was at $30 pre-pandemic
$28 pre-pandemic it should really be $3
today it's not worth $3 because of the
bailer not because what its value is
today they were bailed out there should
be a $3 stock so that's the true value
but the bailout has made it look better
than what it really is and power making
the rates constant go lower and figure
not everywhere to bail everybody out we
understand what they're doing they're
playing the hole socialism on capitals
arming companies and taking care of
these guys which it is what it is I'm
not a fan of it but they're doing what
they're doing
here's a more oldest story the worldís
story is the following no matter what
business you're running people keep
asking me Pat what should I be doing
look at you oh my gosh zoom is killing
it hotels not hotels are not killing or
hotels are getting crushed airlines are
not killing they're getting crushed
uber is not killing you they're getting
crushed right whatever business you're
doing you have to assume your business
model is set up in a way where you are
pandemic proof what do I mean by
pandemic proof now watch this we've had
pandemics in the past before when the
AIDS crisis took place nobody shut down
the government everybody was just more
careful having sex with somebody that
they just
for the first time ace didn't stop
people from going to work we haven't
done this in 8 years but there's a
couple things that's changed in the last
few years and here's what it is let me
explain it to you we are learning in the
last two months the power of media and
the power of politicians why media
manipulates and puts panic into us what
do they do they control politicians
enforce their power they can tell you
California can say if you go outside
somebody can somebody you know that's
working snitch on and we'll tell them
off and we'll go arrest and pay thousand
dollar fine
the lady in Salem they find her a couple
thousand dollars and they threaten to
find her $75,000 who runs a salon or the
lady here in Dallas who's not an
essential business and somebody
determines if you're an essential
business or not the reality is assume
assume if this were to happen again and
you're not an essential business how are
you going to survive during another time
when the media can dictate what to do
and politicians can dictate what to do
and so if there's ever been a time where
this words more powerful freedom it's
today and the way you get this freedom
to choose how you live is by you and
your family getting your millions not
the millions for the Lambos and the
Ferraris and the rolls and the watches
and the homes in the six thousand dollar
suits and their $80,000 watches and the
two thousand dollar shoes I'm not
talking that kind of millionaire I'm
talking about free to choose type of
millionaire freedom
it's what I'm talking about not all this
other stuff so if you're not sitting
around with your board with your
leadership than with your wife with your
husband with your friends with your
peers with your siblings and you're not
figuring out a way to be pandemic fruit
proof
you may also very soon be looking at
stats like this where your customers may
go from 2.2 million a day to 84 thousand
just because of the media's control and
politicians control to enforce laws that
you have no control over you don't vote
for it they told you better do it or
else you also go make your own money so
they can tell you what to do because you
get to be free to choose what you want
to do